[موسيقى]
ضربات الشمس وحوادث السقوط او الحاجه
لانعاش قلبي ابرز الحالات التي تستقبلها
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه بالحرم المكي
طوال شهر رمضان اذ تتعامل الطواقم الصحيه
مع قرابه 800 حاله صحيه يوميا على مدار
الساعه تتعاملنا المراكز الصحيه داخل
اربقه الحرم ومستشفى الحرم مع مختلف
الحالات الحرجه او الخطره منها حالات
الجلطات الدماغيه حالات الجلطات القلبيه
حالات السقوط او الكسور حالات الاصابات
كذلك تعمل على الاخلاء الطبي لها بالتزامن
مع موسم العمره عبر خطط موضوعه ومدرسه مع
كافه الفرق بتجمع مكه المكرمه الصحي
مستشفى الحرمي للطوارئ واجياد وثلاثه
مراكز صحيه اخرى خصصها التجمع الصحي بمكه
المعتمرين والمصلين بالمسجد الحرام بسعه
تصل الى 98 سرير تنوعت بين اقسام العنايه
المركزه والتنويم والطوارئ وجهزت بالكوادر
الطبيه والفنيه تتميز مستشفى ايجاد
الطوارئ ومستشفى الحرم ومراكز الحرم
للخدمات المقدمه للمعتمرين والمصلين حيث
تشمل على خدمات الطوارئ العنايه المركزه
كذلك يشملها الخدمات الطبيه المسانده من
مختبرات واشعه وصيدليه كذلك خدمات طبيه
متقدمه مثل الطب الاتصالي للسكتات
الدماغيه بالاتصال للعنايه المركزه
اسعافات اوليه ميدانيه داخل اروقه المسجد
الحرام تقدمها فرق الهلال الاحمر وفرق
الجمعيات التطوعيه للحالات الصحيه التي لا
تستدعي النقله للمستشفيات كقياس درجات
الضغط والسكري والضمادات
من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي العربيه